what do you do if you catch your kids
smoking pot
as a parent you know like uh what age is
it cool or
you know you walk in they're 14 years
old are you pissed or you're like [ __ ]
okay well um you know it's
funny my kids and this new like
generation are so
square that uh they talk about like some
kid who was a troublemaker because he
got caught
vaping you know in the bathroom and
stuff like that and it's like
it's so weird and innocuous but they're
they're
so kind of anti they grew up in this
kind of anti-smoke anti-drug
anti-everything kind of world that
i can't even really like it's it's weird
to them to smoke pot or to smoke
cigarettes or to
you know drink booze or like drink beer
in the park or like all the [ __ ] we grew
up
doing it just doesn't make make sense to
them it seems
it seems weird to them but you know i
would tell them
i guess my pot explanation would be
it's not going to kill you but it's not
really going to help you either
and uh you know you know you get a
little bit older you want to partake at
a party or something
so be it but you turn it don't turn it
into a [ __ ] lifestyle
because that just becomes that just
becomes your life like you just become
that
that person and i i would feel that way
about anything
booze or pornography or whatever like
i don't know [ __ ] chili dogs like
yeah go ahead and couldn't have one but
don't make it a thing
yeah i i get that did uh
i know jimmy kimmel enjoys a marijuana
cigarette
did you ever get baked with jimmy kimmel
let me think yes
[Laughter]
but you didn't make it a thing well yeah
i think i think most the successful
people
we know just have a balance you know
it's like nothing wrong with pot nothing
wrong with
booze nothing nothing wrong with
anything
when it's time to do it but i don't know
the the wake and bake people i just feel
like
i it's like yeah jimmy likes pot jimmy
would never get up and
rip a bong load and go to work like it's
it's a balance
you know i think everything's a i think
everything's a balance your diet's a
balance
your work is a balance your exercise is
a balance like everything is just this
balance of when is this appropriate
when is it not appropriate whose time am
i
on you know am i on my time is it is it
is it friday night am i done with the
week am i in my bathrobe can i hang out
am i gonna drive
i'm gonna drive the kids like no okay
good i'll have a scotch you know what i
mean like that's how it works it now
doing it you know before you drive the
kids to school in the morning now we're
in there
we're in a situation so it's like the
answer the question isn't like
is having a scotch bad or is having a
bong load bad
it's sort of like when are you doing it
and how much of it
are you doing such a rational take on it
yeah that's why it's like when you came
to his show blacked out he's like
oh hello steve but that's the thing that
it was my [ __ ] plan dude like uh you
were working that was his [ __ ]
yeah dude yeah
dude